okay today I'm going to talk to you
about climate change so first of all
it's really important to know the very
basics of climate change climate change
essentially has been caused by an
increase in atmospheric carbon dioxide
levels and that is a turn is leading to
an increase in global temperatures due
to that greenhouse gas carbon dioxide
absorbing infrared radiation from the
Sun if you want to learn more about this
process please look at the video called
the greenhouse effect there's some other
information we need to know before we
delve deeper into climate change now
another massive contributing factor
words climate change is due to an
increase in the number of livestock
globally such as cattle goats and camels
so due to an increasing population an
increasing demand for meat produce for
example there are more and more
livestock now the livestock actually
produce a lot of this gas called methane
and methane gas ch4 is also a greenhouse
gas that is a similar thing to carbon
dioxide so absorbs heat energy and
results in an increase in global
temperature now the reason why livestock
produce lots of methane is due to them
producing methane through digestive
processes so essentially they produce a
lot of this gas called methane which can
also contribute towards climate change
and increase global temperature so
global warming is an example of climate
change but why is it bad that the world
is getting a bit hotter surely in the UK
that would be a really really nice thing
if it was a little bit hotter so I'm
going to show you the example here of
why it's really really bad news that the
world's getting hotter and the big
answer for that is its melting the ice
caps if we have an increase in glow
temperature the ice caps at the North
and the South Poles will start to melt
now that's not just an issue for the
habitats and the animals that live at
the north and south pole it's a problem
for everyone around the world because as
these ice caps melt it causes a rising
sea level the sea level rises that's
because all of that water is now in the
ocean rather than being stored as ice at
the two poles now around the world that
causes flooding so all of the the areas
that are low down so don't have a
particularly high elevation can be
flooded loads of coastal regions and
areas that that that are quite low down
to sea level close to sea level could be
flooded and this could cause severe
damage and problems across the whole of
the planet now today it's very easy to
gather information about carbon dioxide
levels but we can also find we can
research this stuff called historical
data so we could look back what carbon
dioxide levels were like a long time ago
and there's three main ways that we need
to know that we could do this so first
of all what we can do is we can analyze
fossils by looking at fossils we can
determine the levels of carbon dioxide
that were around when these organisms
were we could also have a look at tree
rings so by chopping down a tree and
looking at the different rings we can
tell how much carbon dioxide there was
at that particular stage of that trees
life we can also quite an interesting
one is within ice sheets there are often
gas bubbles which have been trapped for
a very long time again scientists can
analyze these gas bubbles to figure out
when they how long they've been around
for and the level of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere at that particular stage
so as you can see
there's lots of ways of finding out how
the levels of co2 have changed over time
as well as today using all the modern
techniques of finding carbon dioxide
levels today so how do we help the
situation
what can we do to support the situation
now first of all what we can do is we
can make a switch to using renewable
energy sources because by using
renewable energy sources we're not
burning as much fossil fuel so therefore
we're not producing as much carbon
dioxide however that's something that
governments need to do what could we be
doing individually so a couple of things
that we could be doing right now to help
the situation is first of all we could
use less energy so here's a light bulb
little things like making sure we turn
off lights when we're not in the room
making sure that we have a central
heating turned down to a slightly lower
setting so we're using less energy from
fossil fuels and finally thinking
carefully maybe about our transport do
we always have to drive everywhere maybe
we could cycle so thinking carefully
about things like driving less so
hopefully now after watching this video
we understand a little bit more about
climate change thank you